Since making its debut on the
History channel way back in 2010,
American Pickers has become one of the most
beloved shows on television, airing over 300
episodes and counting. It's also made stars
of series regulars Frank Fritz and Mike Wolfe,
who've managed to turn their love of digging
for gold in the backyards and broken-down
barns of America into a full-blown media
empire — one that's also afforded them a
pair of cathedral-like antique stores, both
of which are now legit tourist destinations.
But there's at least one antique they
found that American Pickers star Mike
Wolfe wishes he had held onto. And
it's not what you probably think.
Wolfe, of course, is famous for his love of
bikes. Whether it's vintage motorcycles or
rusted out old pedal pushers, Wolfe has a thing
for everything two wheeled. So you'd be forgiven
for assuming that his biggest regret is getting
rid of an old Harley or Huffy. You'd be forgiven,
but you'd still be wrong, because the
item Wolfe is most miffed about getting
rid of is actually an old pair of
vintage children's cowboy boots.
Sounds weird, but you know what they say.
"If the boot. Fits."
"Okay, cowboy."
In a 2016 interview with Country Living, Wolfe
gave the whole sad backstory, while also advising
any would-be pickers to listen to that little
voice in the back of your head. When it tells
you to buy something, buy it, and when it
tells you not to sell something, don't sell it.
In Wolfe's case, that pair of kid's cowboy
boots took on a whole new significance
after his wife became pregnant with their
daughter Charlie. He told Country Living,
"Before Charlie was born, I always had
a thing for vintage kids' cowboy boots.
I once found a pair, but I sold them
and immediately regretted doing so."
Luckily, Wolfe got a second
chance and he made the most of it,
turning an interest into a full blown obsession.
"When Jodi was pregnant, I found a second pair.
It felt like fate, so I started collecting them."
Now, Wolfe buys vintage children's
cowboy boots every chance he gets,
and once he buys them, they stay with him;
he showed off at least a half dozen pairs to
Country Living as proof of his dedication.
Wolfe also shared some of his secrets
to amassing a collection like his,
whether your interest is in kids' cowboy
boots, old bikes, or some other type of
rusty gold. His first tip is simply to
follow your nose and see what you find.
That run down barn over there? Who knows,
it might have a massive pile of tiny old
cowboy boots in it. Or maybe it will have
just one gigantic boot instead, who knows!
"Okay, stand it up. That's awesome!"
Wolfe explained,
"I've found my best picks by
driving to the middle of nowhere,
then taking the first gravel road I see."
Of course, there are some dangers in approaching
random houses in the middle of nowhere.
"If someone's putting their boot on
your neck, you gotta get used to that."
And for prospective pickers hoping to spice
up their home with some vintage artifacts,
Wolfe had another big tip: don't stop
at just one, buy multiples if you can.
"They can be really cool when done right.
I like to display objects with similar
textures, time periods, and genres
for visual continuity. In my office,
each shelf has a theme: bikes, motorcycles,
aviation, and cars. It's easy to go overboard,
though, so I like to stick to just one spot."
Like Mike Wolfe with his vintage
bikes and his wee little boots,
once you find something you're passionate
about, the thrill of the hunt and the
excitement of finding a new addition to your
collection is what makes picking so much fun.
Of course, while Wolfe no doubt will be
adding to his boot collection in the future,
he and partner Frank Fritz were derailed
in 2020, as the Coronavirus forced them to
temporarily shut down production of American
Pickers. Wolfe used that time to advocate for
reinvesting in local communities, and to
focus on another part of his collection:
buying and restoring vintage buildings to
help bring back small town Main Street.
"these communities are an important
part of the heart and soul of america"
From boots to boutiques, turns
out that in the world of picking,
there's nothing too big... or too small!
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.